(mellow music)
(music stops)
- Nintendo.
- First Nintendo or the Super Nintendo?
- Did it open?
Was it like a rectangle?
- It was like,
it was the box one.
And you like put the game in it.
- I think she's, I think she's...
(group laughs)
(distorted beeping)
- Okay, how old are you guys?
Just kidding, okay?
(all laughing)
Just kidding.
- What was the first movie
you guys saw in the theaters?
("X-Files" theme)
- I genuinely can't remember.
- The first "Harry Potter."
- "Spider-man 3."
- Spider-man for me as well.
- Yeah, "Spider-man 3"?
- Two.
- Oh.
- "Beauty and the Beast."
- The animated one?
- The animated one.
- Let's bring him over here.
- I was gonna say (laughing)
you might have to go that way.
- Maybe "Toy Story."
- The first one?
- I think so, yeah.
- I think you should come this way.
- Yep, I think so too.
- Do any of you guys play video games?
- I do.
- I just beat "Pokemon."
- Which one?
- "Shining Pearl."
- I have an Xbox.
I also play "League of Legends."
The last video game I played
is probably "Cuphead."
- I think you're older,
because you play some
of the games that like
my older brother and his friends play.
(Jacky and Ignacio exclaim)
- Oh, okay.
Behind or in front of me?
- I think she might be older than you.
- I could see it.
- All right.
- Nintendo.
- First Nintendo?
Or the Super Nintendo?
- That's as far as I know.
I don't even know what
you're saying right now
(all laughing)
- Did it open or was it like,
a rectangle?
- It was like,
it was the box one
and you like put the game in it.
- I think she's, I think-
- What do you guys do for work?
- I'm a lash artist and I write music.
- Same I- music.
That's what I do.
- I'm at a mall
and I sell glass cleaner.
I'm like, "Hey boss,
Let me see your glasses."
- [Jeffrey] Gotcha, gotcha, gotcha.
- "How's it going? Oh awesome."
- I'm an actor.
- Content creator.
Today was the most
embarrassing day of my life.
(breathes heavily and grunts)
- I review pools for a living.
Semi-retired.
(pool toy squeaks)
- Yeah.
- And just go to people's pools.
- Where do you review them?
Like do you post it online?
- Yeah.
(music stops)
- Cool.
- Just like on my Instagram.
- That's cool. Yeah.
(music resumes)
- I think I'm older than you though.
I'm going off of body language.
And then how you talked about your job.
(whistles)
- You know I'm a youthful individual,
I'll say that.
(all laughing)
Take it. Take it.
- Has anyone ever faced any
discrimination based on their age?
- Oh.
- Yes.
All the time.
(laughs)
- Let me tell you,
like corporate world, like
as a woman, or business.
Like I've had my own businesses and
you know I'm talking to
a guy and he's just like,
"Oh, like,
didn't you just get outta high school?
Like, is this your dad's company?"
- Oh yeah. Yeah, yep.
- You know, And I'm just like,
"No sir. Like I started it myself."
Like, you know,
I think a lot of women have to
carry themselves in a different energy
than they do regularly.
Or you have to be more dominating.
You have to present
yourself as more capable
than I think the average guy does.
Like you have things to prove,
I feel like.
- I get the kid a lot,
so people are like, "Oh kid
it's your first job kid?"
Or like it's whatever?
- Yeah.
- So when I used to work retail
and I wanted to get promoted,
they were like, "Oh no
you're just young and
you're just starting out."
Like sometimes I would negotiate
for a certain price point over email.
I'm making my voice sound
very assertive over the phone.
And they would see me
and immediately they would be like,
"Oh we're paying this young
kid too much money for this."
So I went through a phase where
I grew out my facial hair.
I stopped styling my hair as much
because I was like, okay.
I let it get to me too much.
- I think it's really hard to date people.
I remember like my first boyfriend I had
when he showed my picture to his friends,
they were like "why are
you dating a fifth grader?"
Even though we were the same age.
The specific people who
decide to send me DM's
on like Instagram or Facebook
and you can just kind of
tell there's this weird, like
you're not just saying hi
for the sake of getting to know me.
Like it feels very in-
like a little bit insidious.
- I think you two should switch.
These two are switching.
- You think these two?
- I'm switching with him I think.
- These two. And then I'm going,
I'll put myself here.
- I would maybe switch right here.
Dax is a little chill.
- I feel like he's gonna throw us all off-
- Yeah?
- is the thing. Yeah.
- I have a question that may help.
How would you guys describe your fashion?
(seagull calling)
- Beachy with an edge.
Something like that.
- Really specific to what you're saying.
(all laughing)
- Athleisure because I prefer
comfort over everything.
Just hip enough but also like,
just like comfortable enough
- That's giving me millennial.
- Okay, let's swap.
(all laughing)
- What is like your favorite thing to do
to relax or decompress?
- Just make a lot of videos.
- When you say videos,
is that like Twitch or YouTube?
- YouTube and TikTok. Yeah.
- YouTube and TikTok.
Yeah. See, I think he's younger.
I just got into TikTok.
Dax was the hardest one to figure out.
- Dax was giving me like
a little bit older energy
but then like some of the
stuff that he was saying
was more with like the younger stuff.
- I think a lot of people
often tell me that I look
younger than I am.
Well sometimes they tell me-
Like they used to tell me I looked older.
These days they've been
telling me I look younger.
- I think also she may surprise us too.
- Yeah I think so too
- Because she's mature.
- Yeah, possibly.
- But I think you're mature
because you like had to be
to like get the respect
like when you shared your story.
- Oh, that's deep.
Okay. So.
(all laughing)
- I think I'm right right after him
and I think she's right next to me.
You're here and then I think.
There.
- This?
- Yeah.
- No, I don't think so.
- I don't think so, yeah.
- I don't know if I agree with this.
- I would switch with you.
- And then I think you
two should switch too.
- So I'm here.
- You think?
- We'll see.
- Hmm.
- Cause I feel like there's a very
calm demeanor about Dax.
- It's the standing with the hands
behind the back for me.
- Yeah.
- Right between Dax and Kaya.
- Yeah. Right here.
I'll go here.
- Yeah, right, yeah.
- Oh, oh, oh.
- Why are you still in the front spot?
- I'm pretty confident
that I'm in the right spot.
- Okay.
- Pool reviews.
Oh yeah.
(all laughing)
- I think this is it.
- Okay.
I think this is, yeah
- I feel like there is gonna
definitely be a surprise-
- Mm-hm.
- but I just don't know
who it's gonna be at this point.
- Was anyone trying to
be tricky at any point?
- No.
- No. I'm trying
to to get this right.
- Yeah.
(upbeat bouncy music)
- [Host] In our youngest
spot we have Ignacio at 25.
- Okay.
- [Host] In our second
spot we have Jackie at 26.
(Group agreeing excitedly)
- So far, so good.
- [Host] In our third
spot we have Dax at 30.
- [All] Oh!
- Oh okay.
- [Host] In our fourth
spot we have Kaya at 32.
- Okay.
- [Host] In our fifth
spot we have Victor at 34.
- Alright.
- [Host] And in our sixth
spot we have Jeff at 40.
- You're 40?
Dude, I thought-
I was thinking it's 37.
(all laughing)
- I was like 37, 38 like...
- I was like he's 37, 38...
late thirties.
- Yeah.
(upbeat music)
- I was most surprised with Victor,
purely off of just
aesthetic and just his look.
Also because he has really good skin.
- Only knew he was the youngest from
like his aesthetic
and how he talked about
his style and everything,
reminded me so much
of my younger brother around your age.
- I thought you were older than me
but like you were just with it.
Like with the times.
- Body language was
also a lot more mature,
- Mm-hm.
- which was why I placed you a lot higher.
So I feel really bad
about this comment now.
- I feel like there is a focus on
things that you lose as you age.
Physical ability for example,
like I can no longer run as fast
or have as much stamina and
there's less of a focus on
what you gain as you get older.
- Does everyone get told that they look
younger than they are?
- Yes.
- Yeah so I also work
as a substitute teacher.
And so, when I'm in a classroom
I feel like I have to like overcompensate
with like I'm in charge,
don't mess with me.
Because I just find that
a lot of the default
that people have is like,
Oh yeah, she's young.
I can just do whatever.
- Yep.
- Yeah.
- The age thing is still a huge factor.
In a professional field,
in the dating world,
or just like in public
and people judge people like how,
how they choose to respect them.
- Don't ever let the way people view you
affect your dreams and what you wanna do.
- They said,
"Hey, you know your energy's
very, very youthful." You know?
- [Host] Were you cool with that?
- I think it, in my head I was like,
Oh wow.
Because I think I spent a lot
of time thinking, Oh,
okay, I'm getting old.
But then I'm like, oh okay.
Not really.